This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客节目。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在节目中，我将剖析在这个奇特现代世界中展现出的坚韧意志、体能以及抗压能力的种种表现。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历历练后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上搜索数字“2%”。欢迎收听《Look Back At It》播客。从1979年开始，这对我和而言是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义非凡。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们将与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起探讨，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
欢迎在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人群体的亲身经历，进行真诚的对话，这些话题在其他任何地方探讨可能都并不安全，但在这里，你将与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人身披一副盔甲？这向世界传递出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。欢迎在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听并关注《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改过这项特定的检测，对吧？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and trends. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱之陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和趋势，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老
listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thanks for tuning in. It's so great to have you here. Today, we're going to cover a topic that's a little bit different from our usual content on this show. Less relatable to our 20s, more of the psychology. But I know that you all enjoy some of my more science-based episodes. So if you are one of those people, this one is for you. We're going to be talking about the psychology of dreams and daydreaming, where our mind tends to go when we are both asleep and awake and really dig deep into what exactly goes on inside our brains when we enter this nice, cozy fantasy space. dreams are like this massive metaphor, I think, and this massive concept in our lives.
听众，无论你身处世界何地。感谢收听。很高兴你能来到这里。今天，我们要探讨一个与我们节目常规内容有些许不同的主题。它与我们二十多岁的生活关联较少，更多的是关于心理学。但我知道大家都很喜欢我的一些偏向科学类的节目。所以如果你是这类听众，这一集正是为你准备的。我们将探讨梦境与白日梦的心理学，了解当我们入睡或醒来时，我们的思维倾向于去往何方，并深入剖析当我们进入这个舒适美妙的幻想空间时，我们的大脑内部到底发生了什么。我认为，梦就像是一个巨大的隐喻，
They show up in music, in literature, in art, in movies all the time as this like incredible, imaginative landscape and symbol and metaphor. But surprisingly, very little is actually known. Very little is known about dreams. And this topic has been on my list for a while, but it just kind of keeps getting buried amongst some of the more relevant things that have been going on in my life. However, today is the day that we get into it and we give it its time in the sun. Dreams are a really interesting concept to me, but also a really interesting concept in psychology because A, not much is known, but B, there are so many
它在我们生活中是一个庞大的概念。它们经常出现在音乐、文学、艺术和电影中，成为一种不可思议的、富于想象力的景观、象征和隐喻。但令人惊讶的是，实际上人们对它的了解少之又少。人们对梦的了解知之甚少。这个主题在我的待办清单上已经有一段时间了，但由于我生活中发生的一些更紧迫的事情，它总是被暂时搁置。然而，今天就是我们深入探讨它的时候，我们要给它足够的关注。梦对我来说是一个非常有趣的概念，同时在心理学中也是一个非常吸引人的概念，因为A，人们对它知之甚少，但B，存在着众多的
schools of thought. Some say that dreams are our brain's way of sorting through information, of consolidating our memories. Others say that it's our subconscious coming to the surface. And there are some other really weird pseudoscientific theories about future telling, about what our dreams can tell us about what we're thinking about and our repressed desires and what's going to happen to us.
学派。有人说，梦是我们大脑梳理信息、巩固记忆的方式。另一些人则说，这是我们的潜意识浮出水面。还有一些其他非常奇怪的伪科学理论，关于预知未来，关于我们的梦能告诉我们关于我们的想法以及被压抑的欲望，以及将要发生在我们身上的事情。
Ancient civilizations, they used to think that dreams contained like certain prophecies. And it was, Freud, who came up with the idea that they are really our repressed desires coming to the surface. So some of these theories are obviously more valid than others. But what's also fascinating is how scientists and researchers have learned to study our dreams. We obviously cannot peer into someone's unconscious mind and watch their dreams from a computer screen, at least not yet anyways.
古代文明曾认为梦包含着某些预言。正是弗洛伊德提出了它们实际上是我们被压抑的欲望浮出水面的观点。因此，其中一些理论显然比其他理论更有依据。但同样令人着迷的是，科学家和研究人员是如何学会研究我们的梦的。我们显然无法窥视某人的无意识心灵，也无法从电脑屏幕上观看他们的梦，至少目前还不能。
So a huge amount of this research is based on subjective reporting from basically asking people, what do you remember? And then people have slowly begun using things like MRI machines and tracking our eye movements and EEG. But even then, there are so many unanswered questions. And they have found that everyone dreams, which is why this topic I think will be universally accepted and loved and interesting. And a few different things kind of go on in our brain when this happens, which I really want to touch on today. Some of those big questions still remain
因此，大量的这类研究都基于主观报告，基本上是通过询问人们：“你记得什么？”随后，人们才开始慢慢使用核磁共振（MRI）机器、追踪眼球运动以及脑电图（EEG）等工具。即便如此，仍有许多未解之谜。研究发现每个人都会做梦，这就是为什么我认为这个主题会被普遍接受、喜爱和关注。当这种情况发生时，我们的大脑中会发生几种不同的变化，这也是我今天非常想提及的。其中一些重大问题仍然
unanswered. We're going to do our best to answer them today. Why do we dream? Why are everyone's dreams different? Why are they so illogical? What can they tell us about reality? And what is the deal with nightmares and lucid dreaming. We are going to explore all of that today, starting in the brain, working our way into our subconscious and out towards some of the major theories. We are also going to cover the role of daydreaming as a little kind of side quest, a little bit of a bonus, a bonus episode within an episode. And although daydreaming isn't technically dreaming because we are awake, it's still incredibly important to cover. And I think equally, fascinating. I'm going to pop a little study in here, but there have been particular studies that
没有答案。我们今天将尽最大努力来回答这些问题。我们为什么要做梦？为什么每个人的梦都不同？为什么梦如此不合逻辑？它们能告诉我们关于现实的什么？噩梦和清醒梦又是怎么一回事？我们今天将探讨所有这些内容，从大脑开始，深入我们的潜意识，并探讨一些主要的理论。作为一个小小的支线任务、一点小福利，也就是一集之中的彩蛋节目，我们还将探讨白日梦的作用。尽管白日梦在严格意义上不算做梦，因为我们当时是清醒的，但它依然非常重要，值得我们探讨。而且我认为它同样引人入胜。我要在这里插入一个小研究，有特定的研究
have shown that we spend up to 47% of our time awake daydreaming. So let's try and account for what actually goes on during that time because it's a massive portion of our waking hours. So what's going on there? I've also been seeing this idea of maladaptive daydreaming all over my for you pages recently and I'm so fascinated by it. It's definitely something I've succumbed to in the past. So why not talk about it, particularly the role of daydreaming as a form of escapism? Without further ado, let's jump into the psychology and the science behind why we dream, including the unknown role and interesting role of daydreaming. Even if you don't remember your dreams or you think that you don't dream, the chances are that at some stage whilst you're asleep, your brain has fallen into this imaginative fantasy state at least three or more times.
表明，我们清醒时间的47%都花在了做白日梦上。所以让我们试着解释一下这段时间到底发生了什么，因为这是我们清醒时间里非常巨大的一部分。那么这其中到底发生了什么呢？最近我也在我的“为你推荐”页面上到处看到“适应不良性白日梦”这个概念，我对此着迷不已。这绝对是我过去曾经深陷其中的状态。那么为什么不聊聊它呢，尤其是探讨白日梦作为一种逃避现实的形式所扮演的角色？废话不多说，让我们直接切入梦境背后的心理学和科学，包括做梦的未知作用以及白日梦有趣的作用。即使你不记得你的梦，或者你认为自己不做梦，在你睡觉的某个阶段，你的大脑极有可能会至少三次或更多次地进入这种富有想象力的幻想状态。
And most of these distinct dreams last for like five to 20 minutes. And the reason behind why this occurs has a lot to do with both our psychology and our neurology. dreams, they are essentially an involuntary hallucination that occurs when our brains are recharging and resting and they of course exist on a spectrum. Some of our dreams can be incredibly pleasant and sweet. And on the other hand, we have people who are haunted by constant nightmares. Regardless of the content of your dreams, the same process actually occurs. So in general, our brain goes through four. main stages of sleep. And the main distinction between the first three stages and the final stage,
并且大多数这些清晰的梦会持续大约5到20分钟。这种现象发生背后的原因，在很大程度上与我们的心理学和神经学密切相关。梦本质上是一种非自主的幻觉，发生在我们的大脑在充电和休息时，它们当然也存在于一个光谱之中。我们的一些梦可以非常愉快和美好。而另一方面，也有人饱受噩梦连连的困扰。无论你的梦境内容如何，其实发生的过程都是一样的。总的来说，我们的大脑会经历四个主要的睡眠阶段。前三个阶段与最后阶段的主要区别在于，
which is when dreaming occurs, is actually determined by what our eyes are doing. That may seem a little bit strange that our eyes have something to do with this, but let me explain it a little bit further. So stage one to three of sleep, they are all characterized by no eye movement. So beginning at stage one. This only lasts like five to ten minutes. It's that like weird transition period between wakefulness and sleep. And then we move into stage two where I think sleep like technically begins. Our brains begin to slow down. Our heart rate slows down. Our body temperature drops. And our brain starts to produce these really short bursts of rapid activity as it shuts down. And the next stage, stage three. This is where.
即做梦发生的阶段，实际上是由我们的眼睛在做什么来决定的。这可能看起来有点奇怪，我们的眼睛怎么会和这个有关，但让我为您进一步解释一下。因此，睡眠的第一到第三阶段的特征都是没有眼球运动。从第一阶段开始。这只持续大约5到10分钟。那是清醒与睡眠之间那种奇怪的过渡期。然后我们进入第二阶段，我认为睡眠在技术上就是从这里开始的。我们的大脑开始放慢速度。我们的心率变慢。我们的体温下降。大脑开始产生这些非常短暂的快速活动爆发，因为它正在关闭。接下来是第三阶段。这是
our deepest sleep occurs. This is where our body repairs itself and it is the most crucial component of our sleep when we talk and we think about the body repairing itself and the mind regenerating itself. But stage four is where all the action is really going on. This is the show stopper. Our eyes, they begin to move rapidly, which is why it's also known as rapid eye movement sleep, REM for short, and our brain activity most closely resembles our activity during waking hours, because of course, this is where our dreams occur. So we've gone through this, these previous stages of our brain and our body shutting down, but then when we reach stage four, REM sleep, everything fires back up, except for our muscles, actually, which become
我们睡得最深的时候。这是我们的身体自我修复的时候，当我们谈论和思考身体自我修复和心灵自我再生时，这是我们睡眠中最关键的组成部分。但第四阶段才是真正所有精彩活动发生的地方。这是重头戏。我们的眼睛开始快速转动，这也是它被称为快速眼球运动睡眠（简称REM）的原因，我们的大脑活动与清醒状态下的活动最为相似，因为当然，我们的梦就是在这里发生的。所以我们经历了大脑和身体关闭的前几个阶段，但是当我们到达第四阶段（REM睡眠）时，一切都重新活跃起来，除了我们的肌肉实际上变得
entirely paralysed, which I didn't know that, but there we go. And we begin to have our vivid dreams. You are most likely to remember your dreams if you are woken up during this period. And interestingly, a study conducted at Harvard Medical School proposed that REM sleep and dreaming during that time can be viewed as almost like a virtual reality that's been created by our brain. In other words, we sense, we act and we feel what we are dreaming. The rapid movement of our eyes, now used to identify when someone is dreaming, it used to confuse people because they used to think back in the day, back in even as early and recent as the 1900s, that when people were dreaming, they were actually partially seeing our dreams on the back of our eyelids because our eyes were
完全瘫痪——这一点我以前并不知道，但事实就是如此。然后我们开始做生动的梦。如果你在这个时期被叫醒，你最有可能记住你的梦。有趣的是，哈佛医学院进行的一项研究提出，REM睡眠以及那期间的梦境，几乎可以被看作是大脑创造的一个虚拟现实。换句话说，我们能够感知、行动并感受我们正在梦中经历的一切。眼球的快速运动，现在被用来识别某人是否在做梦，过去常常让人感到困惑，因为在过去——甚至早在20世纪初那么近的年代——人们曾认为，当人们做梦时，他们实际上是在眼皮背面部分地看到了自己的梦，因为他们的眼球在转动，就像在扫描周围环境一样。我们现在知道这不是真的，但我们确实进行了大量的视觉化。因此，尽管我们的眼睛没有接收直接输入，这意味着我们在技术上没有看到任何东西，但我们几乎是在生动地将大脑为我们创造的东西视觉化。科学家们利用REM来追踪类似做梦的状态。然后本质上，他们唯一能做的事情就是问人们：“嗯，你梦见了什么？”这就是我们对梦和梦境的了解如此局限的主要原因之一，因为我们无法在实验环境中直接观察它们。当然，最近我们的技术取得了一些进展，包括脑电图（EEG）机器和磁共振成像（MRI）的出现，这让我们能够更深入地了解当我们进入这种奇幻的睡眠状态时，我们大脑的哪些具体区域被点亮了。他们发现，实际上我们的大脑从脑干到皮质的大多数主要区域都是活跃的，唯独额叶除外，这是我们在类似做梦状态下最不活跃的区域。因此，额叶位于最前方。它是大脑中最大的叶。它相对不活跃其实很有道理。因为我们的额叶控制着诸如判断力、逻辑、理性思维、抽象思维和自我控制之类的事情。它某种程度上让我们能够以理性的方式理解事物。因此，当大脑的这一部分关闭时，事情就会变得非常诡异，我们的梦也是如此。
moving as if we were scanning our environment, which we now know is not true, but we still do undertake a lot of visualization. So although our eyes aren't getting direct input, meaning that we're not technically seeing anything, we are almost vividly visualizing what our brain is creating for us. Scientists, they use REM to track dream like states. And then essentially, the only thing they can do is ask people, well, what did you dream about? And that's one of the major reasons why our knowledge of dreaming and dreams is so limited because we cannot directly observe them in an experimental setting. But of course, there have been some recent advances in our technology, including the emergence of EEG machines and magnetic resonance imaging, which allows us to kind of take a
就像我们在扫描周围环境一样在移动，我们现在知道事实并非如此，但我们确实进行了大量的视觉化。所以，尽管我们的眼睛没有接收到直接输入，也就是说我们在技术上没有看到任何东西，但我们几乎在生动地视觉化大脑为我们创造的东西。科学家们利用快速眼动期（REM）来追踪类似梦境的状态。然后基本上，他们能做的唯一一件事就是问人们，嗯，你梦见了什么？这也是我们对做梦和梦境的了解如此局限的主要原因之一，因为我们无法在实验环境中直接观察它们。但当然，我们的技术最近取得了一些进展，包括脑电图（EEG）机和磁共振成像的出现，这让我们能够某种程度上进行
deeper look into what exact parts of our brains are lighting up when we enter this kind of fantasy slumber. And they've found that actually all of our brain is active from the brain stem to most of the major areas of the cortex, with the exception of the frontal lobe, which is the least active area during our dreamlike state. So the frontal lobe front, it's at the very front. It's the biggest lobe in the brain. And its relative inactivity actually makes a lot of sense. So our frontal lobe, It controls things like judgment, logic, rational thinking, abstract thought and self-control. It's kind of what allows us to make sense of things in a rational way. So when this part of our brain switches off, things get really weird and so do our dreams.
这也是为什么我们的梦会如此不合情理、光怪陆离，并且会违背诸如连续性、重力、线性叙事等日常规律。你知道，在梦中我们可以做一些在日常生活中永远无法做到的事情，比如飞翔或穿墙而过，因为我们的额叶没有那么活跃来抑制这些想法，从而让我们的创造力和想象力在没有真正监督者的情况下尽情驰骋。所以我们可能会认为这样的梦没什么大不了的。你知道，它们只是讲给朋友听或者第二天早上就会忘掉的搞笑、有趣的消遣故事。但事实是，做梦对我们的大脑和心灵其实具有难以置信的宝贵价值，
And it's why our dreams can be so implausible and strange and they can defy everyday principles like continuity, like gravity, like linear story. telling, you know, in our dreams we can do things we could never do in everyday life, like fly or pass through walls because our frontal lobe is not as active in suppressing these thoughts, letting our creativity and our imagination kind of run wild with no real supervisor on board. So we might think that dreams like this are not really anything to write home about. You know, they're just funny, entertaining stories to tell our friends. or to forget about the next morning. But the truth is that dreaming is actually incredibly valuable for our brains and our minds,
特别是对于我们如何储存记忆以及如何处理我们的情绪。因此，在我探讨弗洛伊德关于梦的含义的观点之前，我将先回顾几个备受尊崇和接受的主要理论，因为我认为弗洛伊德的观点最为人所知，但也最为复杂、有点令人困惑且带有某种伪科学色彩。所以第一个主要的流派认为，梦的存在是为了帮助我们梳理白天遇到的信息，并巩固我们所建立的记忆。因此，做梦几乎就像是精神上的
particularly how memories are stored and how we process our emotions. So I'm going to go through a couple of the major theories that are well respected and accepted before we jump into our friend Freud's ideas about what dreams meant, because I think that those are the most well-known, but also the most complicated and a little bit confusing and somewhat pseudoscientific. So the first major school of thought is that dreams, they exist to help us sort through the information that we have encountered throughout the day and consolidate those memories that we've made. So dreaming is almost like mental,
春季大扫除。我们在白天接收到如此多的信息，实际上根本没有经过处理，因为我们的大脑太忙了，而且它非常具有选择性，容量有限。然而，这些信息依然存在。因此，当我们睡觉时，大脑必须挑出它想保留的信息和想要忽略的信息。而梦正是这种活动的副产品，因为这种无意识的视觉化通过创造与之相关的图像和故事，有助于巩固我们的记忆。因此，梦往往是我们清醒时经历的事情的反映，它们有助于巩固这些记忆。这就是为什么你可能听过这样的说法：我们在梦中看到的每一张面孔实际上都是
spring cleaning each night. We pick up on so much information during the day that we actually don't process at all because our brain is so busy and it's so selective and it only has limited capacity. However, that information still exists. So when we're sleeping, our brain has to sort out what information it wants to keep and what it wants to kind of disregard. And dreams are a byproduct of that activity because this unconscious visualization aids in consolidating our memories by creating images and stories attached to them. So dreams are often a reflection of things that we have experienced whilst awake and they help with the consolidation of those memories. This is why you may have heard these like suggestions that every face we see in a dream is actually
我们在白天见过的某个人。虽然这很难证明，但基于这个理论，这确实是可能的。另一个理论可能是我的最爱，即梦对于处理我们的情绪至关重要。现在，作为一个经常做生动的梦、且梦境常常反映我生活中经历的事情的人，我真的很喜欢这个理论。对我来说这很有道理。所以，讲个故事吧。我有很严重的幽闭恐惧症，再过几周我要坐飞机去伦敦，从澳大利亚出发大约是两趟13小时的航班，或者是一趟14小时和一趟8小时的航班，实际上我真的吓坏了。我简直惊恐万状。过去几周，几乎每天晚上我都在梦见自己被困在一架飞机上，或者我的一个朋友答应和我一起坐飞机，然后他们走丢了，所以我孤立无援，飞机正在起飞。就像现在谈起这件事，我的胃都在绞痛。因此，我们的梦是面对生活中情感混乱或恐惧的一种方式——尤其是那些我们可能在压抑的恐惧——从我的角度来看，这在主观经验上非常合理。研究还表明，负面情绪比正面情绪更容易在梦中表现出来，因为我们的负面情绪、那些让我们感到不舒服的情绪，
someone we saw during the day, and whilst it is very hard to prove that, it is actually possible based on this theory. Another theory that is probably my favorite is that dreams are essential for processing our emotions. Now, I really love this theory as someone who has really vivid dreams that often reflect things I've been going through in my life. It makes a lot of sense for me. So story time. I have really bad claustrophobia and I'm catching a flight to London in like a few weeks, which from Australia is like two 13 hour flights or like a 14 hour and an eight hour flight and I'm actually, I'm terrified. I'm petrified. The last few weeks like every night, I have been dreaming about being stuck on an airplane or a friend of mine promising me that they're going to
我们在白天见过的某个人，虽然这很难证明，但根据这个理论，这实际上是可能的。另一个我可能最喜欢的理论是，梦对于处理我们的情绪至关重要。作为一个经常做生动、往往反映我生活中经历的梦的人，我真的很喜欢这个理论。对我来说这很有道理。所以，讲个故事吧。我有很严重的幽闭恐惧症，几周后我要搭乘飞机的航班去伦敦，从澳大利亚出发大约是两趟13小时的航班，或者一趟14小时和一趟8小时的航班，实际上我非常害怕。我吓坏了。在过去的几周里，就像每天晚上一样，我一直梦见自己被困在一架飞机上，或者我的一个朋友向我保证他们会
catch a flight with me and then they get lost so I'm all alone and the plane's taking off. Like even talking about it right now, my stomach is like twisting and turning. And so the idea that our dreams are a way of confronting the emotional chaos or, you know, fears in our life, especially those that we may be suppressing, makes a lot of sense anecdotally from my perspective. Research also shows that negative emotions are more commonly manifested in dreams than our positive emotions because, our negative emotions, our uncomfortable emotions. These are normally the ones that we refuse to kind of confront when we're awake, causing them to surface when we are in an unconscious state because our brains cannot, or our minds, I guess, our conscious mind,
通常是我们清醒时拒绝去面对的，从而导致它们在我们处于无意识状态时浮出水面，因为我们的大脑（或者说我们的心灵，我猜，我们的意识）无法阻止这些糟糕的想法发生。我想这就是噩梦存在的解释。不过还有一些其他的观点，比如做梦有助于我们解决问题、排练某些情境，尽管前几天晚上我梦见自己成了蜘蛛侠，但我真的觉得那永远不会发生。没有必要去排练那种情境，但它们对创造力也有好处。甚至有些理论认为这根本没有什么解释。它们只是非常随机的。这只是大脑中不同神经元被激活的副产品，
cannot intercept those bad thoughts from happening. That's the explanation, I guess, for the existence of nightmares. There are a few other ideas, though, such as that dreaming helps us problems, and rehearse certain situations, although I had a dream the other night that I was Spider-Man and I really don't think that is ever going to happen. There's no need to rehearse that situation, but they're also good for creativity. And some theories even suggest that there isn't an explanation. They're just really random. It's just a byproduct of different neurons being fired
而且我们的大脑在睡眠时本来就很活跃，它们没有任何目的，没有任何意义。但在我们转向下一个关于为什么每个人做梦都不同以及诸如噩梦等更有趣的概念之前，我们不能在做一个关于梦的节目时而不谈弗洛伊德。我认为他的理论或许是关于梦的最广为人知但最不被接受的理论。所以在20世纪初，弗洛伊德引入了梦的解析这一概念。因此他争辩说，梦实际上只是——我猜——我们被压抑的潜意识欲望在我们的大脑不够活跃而无法控制或监视我们的思维模式时找到了一个宣泄的出口。这就像是让那些 intrusive thoughts（强迫性思维/闯入性思维）获胜一样。通过检查这些梦的私人内容，我们可以识别出我们真实的欲望，以及真正困扰我们的事情。
in our brain and our brain just being active during sleep and they have no purpose, they have no meaning. But before we move on to this next idea of why everyone dreams differently and some of the more interesting concepts like nightmares, we cannot do an episode on dreams without talking about Freud. And his theory, I think, is perhaps one of the most well-known theories about dreams, but the least accepted. So in the 1900s, Freud introduced this idea of dream interpretation. So he argued that dreams are really just, I guess, our repressed subconscious desires being given an outlet when our brain isn't active enough to control or monitor our thought patterns. It's like letting the intrusive thoughts win. And by examining the private content of these dreams, we can identify our true desires, but also what's really bothering us.
这产生了许多辅助理论，主要与解释出现在我们梦中的某些象征有关。例如，你会找到成百上千篇由专业解梦师撰写文章。他们会告诉你，如果你梦见蛇，你是在想着你生活中的一个有毒的人；玫瑰象征着浪漫；甚至还有一些非常诡异的，比如消防员象征着混乱，或者外星人象征着你觉得自己被生活“绑架”了。这一切都非常古怪，说实话，并不属实。支持这一点的科学依据微乎其微。这只是因为这些象征是我们日常生活中用来解读周围环境的常见原型。
And this has created a lot of secondary theories, mainly to do with interpreting certain symbols that show up in our dreams. For example, you will find hundreds, if not thousands, of articles from people who are professional dream analysts. And they'll tell you that if you dream about snakes, you're thinking about a toxic person in your life, roses, symbolize romance, even some really bizarre ones like firemen, symbolizing chaos or aliens, symbolizing that you feel abducted from your life, It's all very weird and I'll be honest, not true. There is very little science backing this up. It's simply that these symbols are common archetypes that we use in our everyday life to kind of interpret our surroundings.
弗洛伊德说过，其实没那么复杂。比如你不需要字典来解梦。如果你梦见你的母亲，你就是在想你的母亲。如果你梦见葬礼，你正在应对悲伤。当消防员和外星人这样非常超脱的抽象象征登场时，我们大概不应该过度解读。这把我的思路引向了下一个让我着迷的概念：为什么人们做梦会各不相同？好吧，我认为首先，我们天生就是不同的人。个性和视角在其中扮演着重要角色，正如我们清醒时看待世界的方式
And Freud said it's really not that complicated. Like you don't need a dictionary to interpret your dreams. If you dream about your mother, you're thinking about your mother. If you're dreaming about a funeral, you're dealing with grief. when very detached abstract symbols like firemen and aliens come into play, we probably shouldn't read much into it. This brings me to my next idea that I'm so fascinated by, and that is, why do people dream differently? Well, I think to start off, we are all innately different people. Personality and perspective have a big role to play in the same way that we see the world
不同一样，我们的梦也会有所不同。但环境因素同样是非常需要考虑的。某些药物会让我们的梦变得异常生动，因为它们改变了我们大脑中的化学物质，这最终会改变我们的神经元和大、脑解释信息、巩固记忆和处理情绪的方式。所以罪魁祸首主要是SSRI（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂），也就是我们所知的抗抑郁药，众所周知，它们会导致特别生动的梦境甚至噩梦，因为它们使大脑能够获得更多的5-羟色胺，这虽然可能会改善你的情绪，但也会让你的梦境更加强烈。现在，确切的联系尚不清楚，但这种观察已经被证实。
differently when we're awake, we're going to dream differently as well. But environmental factors are also really important to consider. There are certain medications that make our dreams incredibly vivid because they change the chemicals in our brain, which will ultimately change how our neurons and our brains interpret information, consolidate memories, and process our motions. So the main offender is SSRIs, otherwise known as antidepressants, which are known to cause especially vivid dreams or even nightmares because they make more serotonin available to the brain, which, whilst it may improve your mood, also causes your dreams to be more intense. Now, the exact link isn't known, but the observation has been made.
酒精是另一个因素。我们都知道酒精会关闭大脑功能，特别是记忆功能，因此我们才使用“断片（blackout）”这个词。并不是说当你喝太多酒时你肉眼瞎了，或者当你喝得很醉时你没有经历那些事情，只是酒精干预了我们的大脑储存这段时间所产生记忆的能力，这就是为什么如果你度过了一个特别疯狂的夜晚，你就更不可能记住你梦见了什么。当然，还有压力。在心理学中，压力几乎无处不在，甚至影响到我们的潜意识和无意识状态。当我们处于高压状态时，这会影响我们在REM睡眠期间高度
Alcohol is another one. we all know that alcohol can shut down brain functioning, particularly memories, hence why we use the term blackout. It's not like you are physically blind when you drink too much alcohol or that you're not experiencing those things when you're really drunk, just that alcohol intercepts how our brains are able to store the memories that we've made during that time, which is why if you've had a particularly big night, you're less likely to remember what you dreamt about. And of course, there is stress, stress has its fingers in literally everything when it comes to psychology, even our subconscious and unconscious states. When we are highly stressed, this affects the areas of our brain that are highly
活跃的大脑区域。它还会使我们的情绪更加高涨，这也是为什么它与噩梦的产生具有巨大相关性的原因。因此，患有焦虑症或抑郁症的人往往更有可能报告自己经历了强烈的噩梦或糟糕的梦。所以在2018年，这家期刊报道称，生活中更加平静、报告情绪困扰较少的人会做更好的梦。而那些感到焦虑、报告自己真的很焦虑、生活中有些烦心事的人，更有可能做包含负面情绪或恐惧、害怕、沮丧等反应的梦。所以噩梦本质上是令人不安的梦，它们会导致恐惧感、
active during REM sleep. And it also makes our emotions much more heightened, which is why it's massively correlated with having nightmares. So people with anxiety or depression, they tend to be more more likely to report having intense nightmares or bad dreams. So in 2018, this journal reported that people who were more at peace in their life and who reported lower emotional distress, they had better dreams. Whereas those who had anxiety, those who were reporting that they were really anxious, that something was going on in their life that was bothering them, they were more likely to have dreams that contained negative emotions or reactions like being fearful or scared or upset. So nightmares are essentially disturbing dreams and they result in feelings of terror,
害怕感，并会影响——虽然估计数据很奇怪——大约6%的人口。尽管我认为我们所有人都做过噩梦。所以我对此要打个问号。这里是今天的第二个冷知识，那就是：与成年人相比，儿童实际上更有可能做噩梦。有观点认为这是进化的结果。因为儿童体型更小。他们比成年人更容易受到各种威胁的侵害；因此，噩梦可能在一定程度上反映了这种脆弱性。据说儿童中有大约40%的人会做持续发生或频繁发生的噩梦。
feelings of fear and can affect, like the estimates are strange, but around 6% of the population. Although I think that we've all had a nightmare. So I would put that into question. And here's our second fun fact for the day, which is that, children are actually more likely to have nightmares compared to adults. And there has been suggestions that this is evolutionary. So children, they are smaller. They are more vulnerable to more threats than adults. So nightmares may partially reflect this vulnerability. They say that children, like somewhere in the 40% range of children have nightmares that are ongoing or occur more than once.
除了年龄这一因素外，创伤也是一个巨大的影响因素，我们之所以知道这一点，是因为患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人不幸更有可能经历噩梦。哈佛大学曾对在越南服役的退伍军人进行过一项研究，他们发现其中52%的人经历了反复发作的噩梦，相比之下，普通平民人口中的比例仅为6%。不过，我想说的是，你不需要上过战场也会频繁做噩梦。创伤是主观的。我们经常这样说。如果你曾经经历过某种激活了大脑中与恐惧行为相关区域的事情，
alongside age as a factor, trauma is also a big contributor, and we know this because people with PTSD, unfortunately, are much more likely to experience nightmares. There was a study conducted by Harvard on veterans who had served in Vietnam, and they found that 52% of them experienced repeated nightmares compared to that 6% of the civilian and a normal civilian population. The thing is, though, I will say you don't need to have gone to war to still have frequent nightmares. Trauma is subjective. We say that all the time. And if you've ever experienced something that has activated the regions of your brain involved in fear behaviors,
你就会变得特别敏感。我想这也表明了我们的大脑——更重要的是我们的潜意识——有时确实超出了我们的控制范围。除了清醒梦（lucid dreaming）的情况之外。说实话，我对这个了解不多。一开始我其实相当怀疑这到底是不是真实存在的，但根据美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的说法，它是真的。这本质上是在做梦和睡觉时获得有意识的觉醒体验。
you are going to be particularly sensitive. And I think it just goes to show how our brain and more importantly our subconscious is really out of our control at times. except for in the case of lucid dreaming. I'll be honest, I didn't know much about this. I was actually quite skeptical whether this was even a real thing at first, but according to the National Institute of Health, it is real. It's essentially the experience of achieving conscious awareness whilst dreaming and being asleep.
人们可以通过训练来体验这一点。甚至可以达到在做梦时能够引导自己经历的一切的程度。所以我稍微深入了解了一下。它起源于佛教和希腊哲学。有所有这些关于这些人能够引导他们无意识想象力的记录。如果你是一个清醒梦者，你能……给我发个私信吗？我很想听听你的经历，因为我觉得我从来没有做过清醒梦。真的，我不知道。
And people can be trained to experience this. to the point where they can actually guide everything that's happening to them whilst they're dreaming. So I did a little bit of digging. It has its origins in Buddhism and Greek philosophy. There are all of these accounts of these people who are able to direct their unconscious imagination. If you're a lucid dreamer, can you, like, send me a DM. I would love to hear your experience because I don't think I've ever had a lucid dream. Like, I don't know.
问题是有时你甚至分不清。所以如果你是一个会做清醒梦或者自学过如何做清醒梦的人，我真的很想听听你的故事。听起来太着迷了。你知道，我能了解到的全部内容都来自于人们的报告。他们说这并不吓人。唯一会发生的情况是，你可能会觉得自己被困在潜意识里，那里时间变慢了，有时事情变得超级诡异，几乎就像是一次糟糕的致幻剂体验（bad trip）。但显然它不会持续太久。
The thing is that sometimes you can't even tell. So if you are someone who lucid dreams or has taught themselves how to lucid dream, I really want to hear your story. That sounds so fascinating. You know, all I can get from this is people's reports. They say that it's not scary. And the only thing that kind of happens is that you can feel trapped in your subconscious, where time is slower and sometimes things are super strange, almost like a bad trip. But apparently it won't last for long. and some people do not even remember it when they wake up, which is so fascinating to me
而且有些人醒来后甚至完全不记得它，这让我感到非常着迷——
that you can literally be guiding yourself like you're in a video game and then have no recollection of it. Okay, we've spent a lot of time focused on the science behind dreaming, but for a bit of a bonus segment, I really want to discuss daydreaming because although it's a little bit more nuanced, there are some really surprising links to not only our unconscious dream states, but also our well-being. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
你可以像在玩电子游戏一样字面意义地指引自己，然后却毫无记忆。好了，我们花了很多时间探讨做梦背后的科学，但作为一个小小的福利环节，我真的很想讨论白日梦，因为尽管它稍微微妙一些，但它不仅与我们的无意识梦境状态，而且与我们的幸福感之间，都有着一些非常令人惊奇的联系。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧意志、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
体能以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历历练后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上搜索数字“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们第二期讨论快克了，
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以……然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的比赛。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. A-dreaming obviously has one main difference to normal dreaming. It says it in the name, day. It occurs when we're awake.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。欢迎在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱之陷阱》播客。白日梦显然与普通梦境有一个主要区别。名字里就写着：白天。它发生在我们清醒的时候。
and it essentially involves a disassociation from reality by entering into some imagined scenario or some past event or experience almost spontaneously. And it's a form of imagination or a stream of consciousness that actually allows us to take a break from reality for just a brief period. So daydreaming is normally fairly relaxing. It's actually quite pleasant. And that's because it allows our brain to shut off and entertain itself for a moment without needing external stimulation. We get to create these nice stories. We get to comfort ourselves with our day dreams, think about our future, and it can be for five seconds or five minutes. But the reason that researchers believe it takes up so much of our time, roughly 47%, like we said before, don't know where they got that
它本质上涉及一种与现实的脱节，几乎是自发地进入某种想象中的场景或某个过去的事件或经历中。这是一种想象力或意识流的形式，实际上让我们能够从现实中短暂地抽离一小会儿。所以白日梦通常相当放松。它其实相当惬意。这是因为这允许我们的大脑关闭，并在不需要外部刺激的情况下自我娱乐一会儿。我们可以创造这些美好的故事。我们可以用白日梦来安慰自己，思考我们的未来，它可以持续五秒钟或五分钟。但研究人员认为它占用了我们如此多时间的原因，大约47%，正如我们之前所说，不知道他们是从哪里弄来的。
number but 47% sounds, I don't know, about right. The reason is because A, most of the time we don't even consciously recognize when it's happening. You know, it's five seconds. We just are suddenly thinking about our trip a few weeks ago or something that's happening in the future. And B, it gives our brain a chance to pause, restore, recharge, and refocus. We cannot spend, hours and hours focused on only one thing. Our brain just doesn't have the resources. So when it's mentally fatigued or the brain becomes bored, it uses daydreaming to break things up, which I thought was really interesting. It doesn't mean that the brain is necessarily idle. Actually, neuroimaging techniques have shown that the brain is really alive when we're daydreaming. It's just that
这个数字，但47%这个比例，我不知道，感觉差不多。原因在于：首先，大多数时候我们甚至没有有意识地意识到它正在发生。你知道，就这五秒钟。我们突然开始思考几周前的旅行，或者未来将要发生的事情。其次，它给了我们的大脑一个暂停、恢复、充电和重新聚焦的机会。我们不可能连续几个小时只专注于一件事。我们的大脑根本没有那么多的资源。因此，当大脑感到精神疲劳或无聊时，它会通过白日梦来打发时间，我觉得这真的很有趣。这并不意味着大脑一定处于闲置状态。事实上，神经成像技术表明，当我们做白日梦时，大脑其实非常活跃。只是
we're temporarily resting from the task at hand. So breaking up our days, making them more interesting and nuanced. It may also explain why we daydream a lot more when we're bored. I remember in one of the first jobs I had when we would have slow days, I would literally just sit near the counter and daydream like all day because I couldn't use my phone, which is normally what we use to entertain ourselves because the manager would like check the CCTV. every five minutes and I would look up at the clock and like 20 minutes had gone by because my brain wanted to be entertained so it kind of dropped me into this fantasy landscape where I could entertain myself. Findings from neuroscience research Australia has also found that most of the time
我们暂时从手头的工作中休息了一下。因此，把我们的日子切割开来，让它们变得更有趣、更有层次感。这也可能解释了为什么我们在无聊时会做更多的白日梦。我记得在我做过的一份早期工作中，每当遇到无聊的日子，我就会字面意义上地坐在柜台旁，一整天都在做白日梦，因为我不能用手机——我们通常用手机来娱乐自己——因为经理每五分钟就会检查一次闭控电视。我会抬头看一眼时钟，发现已经过去二十分钟了，因为我的大脑想要娱乐，所以它把我带入了一个可以自娱自乐的幻想世界中。澳大利亚神经科学研究发现还表明，在大多数时候，
we are daydreaming we are thinking about the future. This process helps orientate us towards our goals, towards our intentions. It's more fun than thinking about the past because we don't know what's going to happen, but it also helps us rehearse certain instances that are coming up. You know, there is no timeline for how far into the future we can be thinking. We can be thinking about, you know, a date that we're going on tomorrow to what our grandkids are going to look like. It's all very nuanced, but it's a rehearsal mechanism. It kind of plays a role in priming us for what to expect in the future or what we may be anticipating or desiring. Another explanation is that daydreaming is a coping mechanism for dealing with anxiety by allowing
当我们做白日梦时，我们其实在思考未来。这个过程有助于将我们引向我们的目标和意图。这比思考过去更有趣，因为我们不知道会发生什么，但它也有助于我们在脑海中排练即将发生的事情。你知道，对于我们可以把思绪投射到多远的未来，并没有时间限制。我们可以思考明天要去约会的对象，甚至是我们未来的孙辈会是什么样。这一切都非常细腻，但它是一种排练机制。它在某种程度上发挥着为我们即将到来的未来，或者我们可能期待或渴望的事物做准备的作用。另一种解释是，白日梦是一种通过允许
our brain to relax and escape. If your brain is going a million miles a minute about an upcoming decision or something that is stressing you out at work or in your relationship, a nice cozy daydream about your next holiday or whatever you're thinking about, it gives our brain the chance to switch off. And this is where we get the idea of maladaptive daydreaming. I know we've teased it a few times, but this concept is definitely worth the weight because not only is it fascinating, but I promise there are, I think, at least a few of us out there who are going to see ourselves in this description. Maladaptive daydream. is essentially a form of escapism, whereby a person spends an excessive amount of time
我们的大脑放松和逃避来应对焦虑的机制。如果你的大脑正以每小时百万英里的速度飞转，思考着一个即将到来的决定，或者工作或恋爱中让你感到压力的事情，那么一个关于你下一次假期的舒适的白日梦，或者任何你正在思考的事情，都会给大脑一个关机的机会。这就是我们所说的“适应不良性白日梦”概念的由来。我知道我们已经多次预告过这个概念，但它绝对值得我们关注，因为不仅它引人入胜，而且我向你保证，外面肯定至少有几个人会在这种描述中看到自己的影子。适应不良性白日梦，本质上是一种逃避现实的形式，一个人会花大量的时间
daydreaming, often becoming immersed in their imagination in a manner that is at times deliberate and voluntary, as opposed to our usual daydreams that are spontaneous. And sometimes it even incurs without our conscious awareness. So when I say a form of escapism, what I mean is that maladaptive daydreaming, is kind of a mental distraction from the unpleasant aspects of our life, whereby we allow ourselves to be engulfed in our fantasies, where it is safe, where we are in control, and it's normally quite peaceful. So this behaviour, it's especially common as a coping mechanism amongst people who have
做白日梦，经常沉浸在自己的想象中，有时这种沉浸是有意和自愿的，这与我们通常自发的白日梦不同。有时它甚至是在我们没有意识到的情况下发生的。所以，当我说是逃避现实的一种形式时，我的意思是，适应不良性白日梦是对我们生活中令人不快的事物的一种精神分心，在这个过程中，我们让自己沉浸在安全、由我们掌控且通常相当平静的幻想中。因此，这种行为，作为一种应对机制，在那些患有
mental health conditions like anxiety. People who repeatedly engage in maladaptive daydreaming, they tend to, almost lose themselves in detailed and vivid daydreams, almost like reading a book. And they can often pause their daydream and come back to it where they left off because of how compulsive this behaviour is. Another thing is that the links to anxiety, right, and the links to depression, if you are not happy with your life, if something is bothering you, if you wish things were different, there's a really easy way to create that. reality and that's by just imagining it so if you're having a hard time and you find that you're
心理健康问题（如焦虑症）的人群中尤为常见。那些反复进行适应不良性白日梦的人，往往会几乎迷失在详细且生动的白日梦中，就像在读一本书一样。而且由于这种行为具有强迫性，他们通常可以暂停白日梦，并在离开的地方继续下去。另一件事是它与焦虑和抑郁的联系，对吧？如果你对自己的生活不满意，如果有什么事情困扰着你，如果你希望事情有所不同，有一个非常简单的方法可以创造那种现实，那就是去想象它。所以，如果你正经历艰难时期，发现自己
spending hours lying in bed daydreaming it's a coping mechanism not just because it distracts you but it allows you to escape and think about this better version of your life now let's not get confused here daydreaming it is a normal part of our cognitive functioning and at times it's helpful But when we use it to ignore confronting experiences or events or we allow it to interrupt the things that we need to prioritize, this is when psychologists begin to see it as a problem. So although the term is relatively new, it only came about in like the early 2000s and there is limited research, of course, but some initial studies have suggested that about 4% of people engage in maladies. daydreaming, but that increases for adults with anxiety or ADHD, and it rises to about 20% of
花几个小时躺在床上做白日梦，这是一种应对机制，不仅因为它可以分散你的注意力，还因为它能让你逃避现实，去想象生活更好的版本。现在，我们不要搞混了，白日梦是我们认知功能中正常的一部分，有时它是有帮助的。但是，当我们用它来逃避直面那些令人痛苦的经历或事件，或者任由它打乱我们必须优先处理的事情时，心理学家就会开始认为这是一个问题。因此，尽管这个术语相对较新，它大约在2000年代初才出现，而且研究当然有限，但一些初步研究表明，大约4%的人会进行适应不良性白日梦，但对于患有焦虑症或多动症的成年人来说，这一比例会上升到
these people. So one of the theories is that maladaptive daydreaming can actually be a subtle symptom of ADHD, especially amongst girls and women, because we know that symptoms are expressed differently amongst this group of people. And the reason why is because people with ADHD often have hyper focus, they are more easily distracted, and their ability to self-regulate is sometimes impaired. So it doesn't mean that if you are a big daydreamer, you can self-diagnose yourself here and now. It's just one of the less well-known symptoms. And I found that explanation to make like a lot of sense, right, when we think about it logically. That makes a lot of sense why maladaptive daydreaming in conditions like ADHD or anxiety would be
这些人中的20%左右。因此，其中一种理论是，适应不良性白日梦实际上可能是多动症（ADHD）的一个微妙症状，特别是对女孩和女性而言，因为我们知道这类人群的症状表现有所不同。原因在于，多动症患者通常具有高度集中的能力，更容易分心，且他们自我调节的能力有时会受损。因此，这并不意味着如果你是一个爱做白日梦的人，你就可以在此刻自我诊断。它只是不太为人所知的症状之一。我觉得这个解释非常合乎逻辑，对吧？当我们理性思考时，这就讲得通了。为什么多动症或焦虑症等情况下的适应不良性白日梦会
linked. There is no official way to diagnose this condition or this behavior because it's not even yet recognized in the DSM. So it is for now just a term that is used as a descriptor rather than as a diagnosis. However, you can do this test. It's called the maladaptive daydreaming scale, very original name. It's only 14 questions and it's designed to essentially help you identify if this is a problem and if you have this propensity to disengage. I think you can take it online, but always be skeptical of self-reporting tests that are not administered by a professional. We often have a tendency to answer questions so that we get the answer that we wanted to hear, either that you do have maladaptive daydreaming or that you don't. So if you're
产生联系，这非常合乎逻辑。目前还没有官方的方法来诊断这种状况或行为，因为它甚至尚未被收录在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中。因此，目前它只是一个用作描述性的术语，而不是诊断。不过，你可以做一个测试。它被称为“适应不良性白日梦量表”，名字非常原创。它只有14题，旨在帮助你识别这是否是一个问题，以及你是否有这种抽离的倾向。我想你可以在网上做这个测试，但对于未经专业人士管理的自我报告测试，还是要保持怀疑态度。我们往往倾向于给出能让我们听到期望答案的回答，无论是证明你有适应不良性白日梦，还是证明你没有。所以如果你
interested, have a look into it. But I will say, again, Again, the research is very new. It's very fresh. It definitely needs a lot more looking into. Both dreaming and daydreaming, they are such fascinating topics to me because there is some cool research, I will say that, but there is so much that is unknown. I think with most areas of psychology, we tend to have somewhat of a good grasp about why things happen, how they happen, what these mental phenomena look like. But with dreams, We are so limited because they are entirely internal and private in nature. And I think it's the fact that they occur when we're unconscious that means that we can't observe them how we would a normal behavior.
感兴趣的话，可以去了解一下。但我必须说，再次强调，这项研究非常新。非常新鲜。它绝对需要更多的深入研究。无论是做梦还是白日梦，对我来说都是非常迷人的课题，因为确实有一些很酷的研究，我要这么说，但还有太多未知的领域。我想在心理学的大多数领域，我们往往对事情发生的原因、发生的方式以及这些心理现象的外在表现有了相当不错的了解。但对于梦境，我们的局限性太大了，因为它们完全是内在的和私密的。而且正是因为它们在我们无意识时发生，导致我们无法像观察普通行为那样去观察它们。
But it's also really beautiful that our brains have been able to create a way for us to build these entirely private worlds and storylines and characters just for our enjoyment. I think that's just so remarkable that we have evolved to be able to dream and that our brain can be so creative even without our conscious input. Like I just, I think that's incredible. I think that's so beautiful that we fall asleep and we have a whole new universe, a whole new story, a whole new world waiting for us there. Anyways, I think that is all we have time for today. but I'm going to finish with one more fun fact that I found really interesting. I didn't know this, but blind people can actually see images in their dreams, which is insane to me because, well, they have no point of reference.
但这也是非常美妙的一点，我们的大脑竟然能够创造出一种方式，让我们能够建立这些完全私密的世界、故事情节和角色，仅仅为了我们的享受。我认为这太了不起了，我们进化出了做梦的能力，而且即使没有我们的意识参与，我们的大脑也能如此富有创造力。我觉得这简直不可思议。我觉得当我们入眠，并且有一个全新的宇宙、一个全新的故事、一个全新的世界在那里等待着我们，这太美妙了。无论如何，我想这就是我们今天所有的全部时间了，但我将用一个我发现非常有趣的冷知识来结束今天的节目。我以前不知道这一点，但盲人其实可以在梦中看到图像，这对我来说简直太疯狂了，因为，嗯，他们没有任何视觉参照物。
You know, if I could make one scientific discovery in my life, I think it would be being able to see other people's dreams because I would love to see the kind of world that it's created in the mind of someone who was blind. That is so fascinating and I think it really goes to show how much of it is really our brain rather than us actually seeing these images that it's created. So so many fun facts today, so many interesting findings. I love doing some of these more science-based episodes. I know there wasn't much in terms of its relationship to our 20s,
你知道，如果我能在自己的一生中做出一个科学发现，我想那将是能够看到别人的梦境，因为我很想看看在盲人的脑海中创造出的是怎样一个世界。这太迷人了，而且我认为这确实表明，很大程度上这其实是我们的大脑在起作用，而不是我们真的在“看到”大脑所创造的这些图像。所以今天有太多的冷知识，太多的有趣发现。我喜欢做一些这种更偏向科学的节目。我知道这与我们二十多岁的关系并不是那么紧密，
but there was so much fascinating psychology behind this. And I just had to do it justice. I had to cover this. I just think it is so incredibly fascinating. And, you know, everyone in their 20s dreams. So there we go. There's the link that we needed today. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode.
但其背后有太多迷人的心理学知识。我必须公正对待它。我必须讲讲这个。我只是觉得它太不可思议了。而且，你知道的，二十多岁的人都会做梦。所以好了，这就是我们今天需要的联系。所以我真心希望你喜欢这期节目。
I hope you learned something. I hope it's going to lead to fun dinner table conversations or fun workplace conversations. Dreams are just so cool. I said it before, but it's just the most beautiful thing that our brain allows us to do that. So thank you for joining me on this fun little ride that we had. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, IHeart, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help this show to grow and reach new people. If you have an episode suggestion, please follow me at That Psychology Podcast and send me a DM.
我希望你学到了一些东西。我希望这会引发有趣的餐桌谈话或职场聊天。梦境实在是太酷了。我之前说过，大脑允许我们做到这一点，这是最美好的事情。所以感谢你和我一起体验这段有趣的旅程。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify、iHeart或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。这确实对节目的成长和接触新听众非常有帮助。如果你有节目建议，请关注我的账号“That Psychology Podcast”并给我发私信。
Tell me what you want to hear. I love when people have had something going on in their lives and they want to know the psychology behind it. That's the whole purpose. So follow me over there if you feel called to do so. And we will be back on Tuesday for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app,
告诉我你想听什么。我喜欢听人们生活中发生的事情，并想了解其背后的心理学。这就是全部目的。所以如果你愿意的话，去那边关注我吧。我们周二会带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是iHeartRadio应用上的TWA%（注：此处原文ASR笔误），
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived. It was described it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
苹果播客，或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚克斯·英格利什。每一期，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。我们与朋友、喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起描述它。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方其实都不安全的坦诚对话。但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲？它向世界传达出一个信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次伪造了这个特定的测试，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。